this program is being presented to you
by the Harris international winter
school on gravity and lights welcome to
the W e Reyes International winter
school on gravity and light the first
lecture was about the notion of topology
and topological spaces
maddis what this tutorial will be about
the first exercise are simple
multiple-choice questions
they are designed to spark discussion
and as a self test
you shall tick the rod correct
statements but not the incorrect ones so
let's start in Part A we look at a
topological space the first answer says
that it is defined by a set a topology
and an atlas that is not true since the
topological space is only a set occurred
with a topology an atlas is additional
structure required for a topological
manifold that will be introduced later
on a topological set is a set without
any further structure that is also
incorrect since a topological space is a
set equipped with a topology and that
the topology is further structure a
topological space defines a notion of
open sets well that is correct since a
topology defines what open sets are a
topological space always has integer
dimension which is the 4th answer well
that is also incorrect since we cannot
speak of dimension when dealing with a
topological space and last a topological
space allows to check the continuity of
a map from the underlying set to itself
yes the
is correct a topological space is the
minimal structure required to define the
continuity of a map so in Part A we had
two correct answers three and five Part
B deals with the chaotic topology on a
set M it says that it cannot be defined
on the natural numbers n that is not
correct of course we can equip the
natural numbers with the chaotic
topology the second answer is a consists
of all subsets of M which is also not
correct since that only consists of the
empty set and the set M itself the
discrete topology would consist of all
subsets of M the chaotic topology on is
that contains the empty set well that is
definitely correct since this is the
first axiom of a topology it is the
coarsest topology on M so here we have
to introduce what corsa means on
topologies so we can define that a
topology
o to is causa then then each apology a
one
if otwo is contained in oh one please
mind that the notion of of being
contained in another set doesn't define
a total order since we cannot compare
since there are there can be topologies
that can not be said to be subsets of
each other so we can only say for some
topologies that they are subsets of
other topologies and thus we have a
partial order but if we can say that a
topology is contained in another
topology we say it is closer than the
other and for the chaotic topology that
only contains the empty set and the set
M itself we clearly see that this is the
causes - topology on M and the last
answer for this question is that the
chaotic topology makes all Maps F from n
to our set M continuous where the domain
n may carry an arbitrary topology so
there we have to look at the notion of
continuity and thus we have to look if
the preimages of open sets are open in
the domain so open sets on the target M
are just the empty set and the set M
itself the preimage of the empty set is
clearly the empty set and the preimage
of the set M is the set N which both are
definitely open in a topological space n
so this answer is correct
in Part C we consider a map F from M to
n between topological spaces M equipped
with the topology om and n a cook with a
topology Oh N
in the first answer it says that
continuity can only be defined if M is
our m and n as our n for some positive
integers m and n well that is wrong
since we don't need to restrict
ourselves through the real numbers as
sets but we can choose an arbitrary set
and equip it with a topology and then
check for continuity of the map so that
is wrong for some maps one can arrange
for the topological notion of continuity
to coincide with the undergraduate
analysis notion of continuity if we
equip so if we choose if we now choose M
is our M and n is some our n like in the
first answer and but when we equip both
with the standard topology then we can
then we find that the topological notion
of continuity is equal to the under
Gretchen air and a graduate notion of
continuity with the epsilon-delta
criterion so that is correct
continuity of a map can only be defined
for some topologies no that is wrong we
continuity of a map is defined for any
topology continuity is a property of a
map that only depends on the topology om
that is also not correct
since continuity says that pre images of
open sets are open in the domain so we
need to know what open sets in the
target are as well as on the domain and
thus we need the topology on the target
o n as well as the topology on the
domain om
we need both so that is wrong and the
last answer is choosing the discrete
topology on M makes all maps from M to n
continuous
again this is correct now since the
discrete apology and M are all the
subsets of M and now we can equip the
target end with an arbitrary topology
and we find that the pre images of open
sets on the target are always open on
the domain since we choose the discrete
topology namely the power set on M as
our open sets so it is correct and the
last part of this exercise is about the
notion of open and closed sets on
topological spaces so a subset you that
is a subset of M for topological space
may be open and not open at the same
time whether there's nonsense
either it is open or is not open but not
both at the same time it may be open but
not closed well that is correct as an
example look at M is equal to the real
numbers we equip it with the standard
topology and then we look at the
interval U is the open interval from 0
to 1 where 0 and 1 are not included this
subset is clearly open and it is not
closed since the complement which is
minus infinity to 0 included and UNIF
unified with the
interval from one included to infinity
is not open so this is wrong it is right
a subset may be closed but not open this
is also correct
we again give an example with the real
numbers equipped with standard topology
and now we look at the interval 0 1 with
0 & 1 included this interval is closed
but not open it may be open and closed
this is also correct so we show this in
the lecture that for a for an arbitrary
topological space M the set M itself is
open and closed in the topology at the
same time so this is correct and the
last answer that it may be not open and
not closed is also correct again an
example for that we take the real
numbers and look at the interval 0 1
with 0 included and 1 excluded so this
interval is neither open nor closed and
thus this answer is correct this was the
first exercise now we move on to the
second exercise which is about
topologies on a simple set the first
question is to write down the definition
of a topology Oh on a set M so
Oh which is a subset of the power set of
em on a set M is called a topology on M
if three criteria are fulfilled the
first one is that the empty set is an
element of O as well as the set M is an
element of o the second one is that for
two sets U and V that are both elements
of the Chapel of O also their
intersection is part of the of O and the
third one third and last one is that for
a family CA where C alpha where alpha is
the element of some index set a if we
have this family C alpha as an element
of O then also the Union with respect to
all these alpha in the index set of the
C alpha is also an element of the
topology this is the definition of a
topology on a set M now we have an
example we have the set M that contains
the elements 1 2 3 & 4 is clearly a set
and the question is plus a 1 as the set
of the empty set aside with the element
1 and the set M itself constitute a
topology on M we see that
first criteria is fulfilled the empty
set is an element of oh one as well as M
is an element of oh one the second
criterion is also fulfilled for example
the intersection of the empty set with
set the element one gives again the
empty set which is an element of oh one
or intersection of the set with M and
one with M it's just the center with the
one we can look at all these
possibilities and see that all
intersections are again in oh one and
thus the second criterion is fulfilled
and also the third criterion is
fulfilled as each unification as each
as we can look at as the union of all
sets for example set with the M + 1 + M
which is again M o the empty set the
70mm 1 the element 1 they are all again
part of a 1 and we see that of all
unions we can imagine with these sets in
a one we always land again in a one thus
all Criterion's are fulfilled and a one
is a Tripoli G on M
now the question is is the topology Oh -
that is defined here also in topology so
we can again check the empty set as well
as the set M are both in Oh - all the
intersections of elements in otwo are
again elements of Oh - so second
criterion is also fulfilled however if
we check criterion three we see that if
we consider the union of the sets one
and two which is the set with the
elements one two that this is not in a
chew thus we have a violation of
criterion 3 here and OH - is not a
topology on em and the last question is
are there other topologies than the ones
recognized so far
well definitely there are so there are
for example the chaotic topology or the
discrete topology and many many more
so this was exercise two which deals
with tuple with topologies on a simple
set and now we move on to exercise three
about continuous functions so what is
the definition of a continuous map so
definition of a continuous map is just
that pre images of open sets in the
target are open in the domain so let now
MP again the set one two three four and
we considered the identity map on M it
is defined by taking the element one to
itself and taking element 2 to itself
and so on now we want to check if the
identity map is continuous if we equip
the domain with the chaotic topology and
the target with the topology Oh target
that contains the empty set and set one
enter set M itself so clearly our target
is a topology on M so we can look at the
pre images of open sets we look at the
pre image under the identity map of the
set one that is an open set in the
target and we see due to the identity
map mapping all elements to itself that
this is the set with the element 1 but
the set with the element 1 clearly is
not an element
of the chaotic topology with which we
equipped the domain so the pre images of
open sets are not open thus the identity
map is not continuous with respect to
the chosen topologies but now we
consider the inverse identity map it
also maps from n to M but now the target
is equipped with the take chaotic
topology and the domain with the other
topology first we provide the values of
the inverse identity map
well not as easy since also the inverse
identity map only takes elements from
the set to itself so we get one map 2 1
2 2 2 and so on now we want to check
whether it is inverse identity map is
continuous
therefore we again look at pre images of
open sets now the domain is equipped
with the other topology and the target
is equipped with a chaotic topology thus
we can only look at the pre images of
the open set which is the open set which
is an element of O so we call this
topology here o the topology of the
domain and the other pre image under the
inverse identity map is off the set M
itself
well palace M itself which is also an
element of O fast
the inverse identity map which we
denoted IDM inverse is continuous with
respect to the chosen topologies now we
have seen how the notion of continuity
is directly impacted by the chosen
topologies on domain and target in
exercise 4 which is already the last
exercise of this problem sheet we deal
with the standard topology on Rd so the
first question is to sketch the real
intervals that are given in the table
below and decide whether they are open
or not so the interval 0 1 with 0 & 1
excluded we can draw easily in this way
and clearly does this open in the
standard topology as we can find as we
can at every point find open balls the
completely lie in this interval for the
interval 0 1 with 0 included which we
could draw like this we cannot find open
balls anymore so consider we are sitting
here with consider the point 0 we can
not find an open ball around the point 0
such that it completely lies in this
interval plus this interval is not open
the other case would be that series
exclude
but one is included that doesn't change
anything since now we fail at the point
1 and again the set is the interval is
not open and the interval with 0 & 1
included it's also not open now we look
at the union of the open interval 0 1
and the open interval 0 to 3 which is
just pictured like this so we see the
union of open sets is of course again
open that was a criterion for a topology
and of course we can also can find open
poles at any point in these in this
interval so that they lie completely in
this interval so now we have understood
what open intervals on the real line R
so what about subsets of R 2 we now
consider 6 different subsets of R 2
which is equipped with a standard
topology
note that the this frame around the
subsets has no meaning it is not a
rectangular area of R 2 but rather it's
it represents all of our two so this is
all of our two here and we have this
subset and weekends and we easily see
that for each point we can find such
open bolts such that the ball completely
lies in the subset and thus this up
that is open also the second example is
an open subset of r2 you see and every
point you can find open balls that are
completely in the set
thus a subset is open the third example
here it's not open anymore
you could you could consider this point
here and then you can find no open ball
that completely lies in the set itself
it always said some outside territory
thus this set is not open in our tube
here this was an open interval in our
however now this subset is not open in
r2 as we can find no open ball in r2
that completely lies in this open
interval on our so the open interval on
on our is not open in r2
now the fifth example here is directly
the compliment to the second example
so the compliment was open that means
that this set is closed
and now we want to check whether it is
open well no it's not we can see this
easily that there are no open bolts for
example for this point and the last
subset of r2 is again a union of open
sets and such a union of open sets is of
course again open so now we have seen
examples of open intervals in our as
well as in r2 and now we look at a
function f that map's from the real
numbers to the real numbers and is given
by the following graph now top both
domain and target of this map are
accrued with a standard topology and we
want to know whether this function is
continuous so continuity means that
three images of open sets are open and
now we look at an open set here in the
target which could be for example
the set we see that it's pre-image
goers
to here however this point is included
in the interval and in the last question
we saw that such an interval where 1 4
is included is not open in R with
respect to the standard topology thus
this function is not continuous this we
would also expect from our intuition
gained from undergraduate analysis as we
see that this function makes a jump
which we say should be is not to be not
continuous
so for maps on the reals equipped with a
standard topology our topological notion
of continuity coincides with the notion
from undergraduate analysis